[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
June 7th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
more workers are using generative
artificial intelligence tools like chat
GPT Wall Street Journal reporter to Ping
Chen joins us to discuss how it's
helping professionals save time and
boost their income so tipping artificial
intelligence seems like it's something
new but what are some examples where
it's been in use for quite some time
there's lots of ways that artificial
intelligence has been used to help with
processes like customer service so for
example if you're calling it's quite
possible that the agent on the other end
of the line has been working with AI
powered software that can help hear
what's going on in conversation
transcribe it have that transcription be
processed and then offer feedback or
suggestions to the agent
in terms of what they should be saying
to you then also for regular consumers
it's something that they would encounter
on a perhaps daily basis with tools like
Siri or Alexa so how do they work and
are they easy to use I spoke with folk
who had really no coding background
really no technical background
whatsoever and yes we're absolutely able
to start using those tools quite readily
in their own work lives so with one of
the designers that we spoke with who was
trying to generate an image it was
typing in fun quirky car fun quirky car
retro like you know and adding on more
and more descriptors until he landed on
the image that he wanted and then taking
it into another program more traditional
program like Photoshop or what have you
and working on it from there but the
actual input process he and others have
found and of course it depends on the
tools some of them you do need more of a
technical background but certainly for
things like chat GPT and mid-journey as
well really quite accessible so you
really don't have to be a computer
expert to use these tools yeah not all
the folks we spoke to did have a coding
background or those skills one lawyer
that I was talking to you know
absolutely no such technical background
but she was using chat GPT quite
fluently to try and generate articles
for a website that she was building in
other cases you know we also spoke with
a marketer who likewise didn't have a
technical background but was using chat
CPT to generate content for his
marketing business so yeah I think some
someone in curve involved of course like
with anything but not that substantial
now in your story you spoke to people
who are Freelancers and work in small
businesses how can artificial
intelligence be used by people outside
those fields somebody maybe in a
full-time job or who's not in a small
business yeah well the tools are
applicable to really any kind of work
context any sort of White Collar work
context it would just be a question
obviously of what your company's
regulations are but for workers there's
a there's a lot of different ways that
they can be drawn on I spoke to one who
was using it to check kind of his work
before going to meetings with clients he
would have his team of course prepare
their remarks and then he would also
just check the chat CPT to see what
would be recommended you know say I have
a client meeting with so-and-so and we
want to brief on XYZ what should we say
and then he would compare the results
and make sure that his team is covering
its bases I've also heard from workers
who are using Chachi BT to write emails
to colleagues sometimes to spruce up
emails to clients say you've got already
an email written but you know write it
in a more energetic tone or make it
sound more exciting those sorts of
applications too so there's a million
ways you can use it it's just really a
question of what are some of the
guidelines and what are your workplaces
policies which is why you know we do see
a lot of Freelancers and sort of small
business owners who are maybe more
actively using it because they're less
Bound by such constraints but really the
uses are
um really very widely applicable Yeah
you mentioned that the small business
owners and Freelancers they can use
these tools more freely because they're
not really constrained by legal hurdles
in large companies what kind of hurdles
would those be well it's everything from
questions around copyright when we're
talking about generating art there are
ambiguities that companies are still
working through questions of whether or
not using these tools are should be seen
as cheating or fair and so some
companies that are still having that
discussion others who have very
substantive concerns about privacy so
really a gamut of issues but again you
know I think there are a lot of
efficiencies again and so we do see
companies including a large Enterprise
companies starting to experiment with
these tools but
so we certainly do see companies and
especially small smaller companies
experimenting with these tools for
Enterprise customers and larger
businesses it's a much more complicated
equation you hear about AI chat Bots
making things up or hallucinations what
are some of the risks that go along with
using tools like this well I think for
the moment you know a lot of the folk
that I spoke to for the speech really
feel like they're getting an edge over
some of the competitors with these tools
right because if you're generating pitch
decks using some of these tools saving
time that way and able to come with much
more custom kinds of imagery or specific
content that's really tailored to your
clients in a fraction of the speed
that's all to the good I think though as
as these tools become more widely
adopted there are questions of course
about how clients are going to be
viewing these of these sorts of tools
not everyone that I spoke to was
necessarily telling clients that they
were using them as their competitors
also catch on there's a question of you
know how long will these sorts of
advantages hold
and I think uh fundamentally there's you
know sort of as one user I was speaking
with was saying like at some point you
know what's my ad value and
um the concern of well we're using these
tools and in some ways it's just racing
the bar on what I need to be doing too
so in a past generation workers were
concerned about being replaced by robots
and this person was concerned about
being replaced by the AI tool well he
was you know saying very helpful to now
but of course there's anxieties about
what this might look like in the future
that's Wall Street Journal reporter to
Ping Chen and that's your money briefing
I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall Street
Journal
thank you